it's monday the 6th of december
nowhere to hide the government reveals
its 10-year plan to tackle drug kingpins
and could middle-class users also face
losing their passports
that as the common speaker tells sky
news he plans to call in police after
claims of drug abuse in the houses of
parliament
a warning from a coveted vaccine creator
the next virus we encounter could be
more lethal as recorded cases of omicron
continue to rise
in breaking news ousted leader and
sang-su chi is sentenced to four years
by a court in myanmar
thousands of residents are still without
power as the uk prepares for a second
major storm to hit we are live for you
in northumberland this morning
volcano eruption the towns blanketed
with ash in indonesia as rescuers battle
poor weather in the search for survivors
the british teenager who survived a
crocodile attack in zambia speaks out
about her ordeal
i fully accepted the fact that i was
going to lose my phone
and i accepted that and i said to all my
friends it's fine i've lost my food i'm
still alive
[Music]
good morning everybody nowhere to hide
is the government's message as they
reveal a 10-year plan to
to tackle drug crime in england and
wales gangs drug kingpins and even
middle-class users will be in their
sights reports this morning harsher
punishments could be dished out to deter
drug users such as removing their
passports and also their driving
licenses the policing minister kit moth
house is with us shortly first here's
some of the key announcements for you
the government will invest 300 million
pounds in closing down gangs involved in
the drugs trade and the police will be
tasked with carrying out more than six
thousand disruptions against their
activities
the strategy also outlines plans to
dismantle two thousand more county lines
distribution routes having already
closed around one and a half thousand in
the last two years
the strategy will also include the
largest ever funding increase for
tackling addiction and repeat offenses
after the home office said there are as
many as 300 000 heroin and crack cocaine
addicts in the country who are
responsible for almost half of all
acquisitive crimes such as burglaries
and thefts
joined now by the policing minister kit
malthus mr multis good to have you with
us this morning thank you for joining us
it's a 10-year plan i believe to combat
drug-related crime could it really
involve taking people's past ports away
from them
well in time yes i mean one of the
things we're focusing on to begin with
as you quite rightly said k is the
disproportionate amount of crime driven
by heroin and crack addicts but we also
need to reflect on the fact that there
are an awful lot of kind of lifestyle
users of cocaine and other drugs out
there who are driving much of the
violence and the the degradation that we
see from drugs overall and so what we're
going to do is publish a white paper
next year looking at what we can do to
try and turn them away from their
particular habits and that might involve
we hope uh interfering in their lives in
a way that brings about behavioral
change we've seen that in other parts of
government policy if you look at the
child support agency where people
i was responsible for that for a while
where people don't pay their support
courts do have a power to remove their
passport and their driving license these
are the kind of impositions on a kind of
lifestyle which we hope will bring about
behavior change over the next decade
if it's true that 11 out of 12 locations
tested in the house of commons tested
positive for class a drugs it could be
that some of your colleagues find
themselves in that position
well i i hope not there are obviously
several thousand people who work on the
estate and i'd be surprised if there
weren't some lifestyle uses of drugs
amongst them i have to say but what we
want to try and do is get to a situation
where the police and other authorities
are concentrating as much on that part
of the the drugs industry as you like if
you like as they are on crack and heroin
we need to make sure that we drive crime
numbers down overall the drugs industry
brings a lot of violence and degradation
and victimization into this country and
so attacking the supply which as you say
we've been doing with real vigor over
the last two years and accelerating that
over the next decade is critical but we
also have to look at demand demand at
the sharp end and heroin and crack users
who need to be treated for their
addiction as well as punished for their
crimes but also then moving on to the
much bigger group of those who are
driving this trade of powder uh coming
from across the world to the uk who are
driving that trade we need to turn them
away from as well and deal with their
offending in their behavior
you talk about lifestyle use it makes it
sound almost acceptable in the house of
commons
well it's not acceptable i mean i've
been struggling for a word people say
recreational they call it middle class
lifestyle whatever it is it's use that
is driving a lot of violence and a lot
of misery and there are lots of young
people as you will know in the capital
and elsewhere who are dying as part of
that trade being stabbed and killed you
know just in the last two years we've
rescued about 4 000 young people who've
been dragged into the drugs trade as
part of county lines and so the idea
that that kind of casual usage on a
saturday night is somehow a victimless
crime is is ridiculous and immoral and
we think that those people need to focus
on their behavior we need to find a way
in society that we make it unacceptable
we impose on their lifestyle in the same
way that over the last 20 30 years we've
made drink driving um unacceptable
socially we'd like to do the same with
drugs
labour says it's your fault because
you've cut 100 million pounds from drug
treatment services since you came to
power
well obviously labour do a lot of
shouting and arguing about the past but
in truth the drugs industry has changed
significantly over the last 10 years we
saw declines in usage uh a cert to a
certain decline in drug-related crime
and then that industry sort of reacted
right it did what most industry would do
it found a better product made it
cheaper new ways to distribute it open
new markets it's a very interesting
economic and business dynamic if you
like uh that meant that we needed to
address it now whatever three years ago
we commissioned dave carroll black to
have a look at drugs we're so alarmed
about it this strategy today is a
response to that but it builds on the
work we've been doing for the last two
years closing down these hundreds of
county lines across the country building
these recovery projects in places like
blackpool and norwich and middlesbrough
where we've brought everybody together
to turn lives around particularly those
on on heroin now we can turbo charge
that effort uh going forward the
critical change for us k
is that we recognize that this is a
business right what these drug dealers
are doing is trying to make money and if
we can interfere in their business both
in terms of reducing demand but breaking
the supply chains then hopefully will
drive activity down once and for all
okay let's talk about omicron should
read that greek letter that none of us
thought we would ever know much more
about more than 50 percent rise in a day
of omicron cases
but the impact on deaths and
hospitalizations has been minimal in
other words there haven't been any at
this stage are we massively overreacting
well i don't think we are we're being
proportionate and precautionary i mean
obviously we don't know completely what
this variant is going to do we know it
seems to be quite infectious but we
don't know yet exactly how
difficult it's going to be for people's
bodies to cope with that research is
ongoing we've got world-beating science
you know world-leading scientists who
are able to give us those answers over
the next two or three weeks in the
meantime what the prime minister said is
said look let's be careful right let's
take it steady let's wear masks in
certain areas where we think there's
likely to be uh transmission let's think
about travel
more carefully and make sure we do
testing at the border to restrict the
virus coming in to buy us a bit more
time but fundamentally let's be
proportionate about it and get on with
our lives to a certain extent and try
and have as merry at christmas as we
possibly can so we're learning as we go
don't forget omicron is quite a way down
the alphabet that means between delta
and now we've been through a number of
variants that haven't got very far let's
see where this one goes but for the
moment steady
okay get you with your greek studying at
school um the us though has an awful lot
of scientists um as well world class two
including dr anthony fauci who's top of
the tree
and he's told the leader there that
actually the travel ban should be lifted
um should we do the same
well let's see as i say okay we've got
these amazing scientists at portland
down just on the edge of my constituency
who are doing that research right now
subjecting this virus to various tests
to see how it responds see what we know
we can learn about it and you know we
know that the work we do here in the uk
has been leading the world and informing
much of what the world does around this
virus so i have great confidence that
they'll give us a much clearer picture
of the next two weeks and until then
it feels to me doesn't it to you that we
should be cautious i think
all i'm doing is trying to clarify
whether if the us is lifting the travel
ban we are saying okay good for you but
we're not going to do ours this side of
christmas
well i think look we will be informed by
what comes out around the world what the
prime minister said the restrictions
will be reviewed in three weeks we need
a bit of time to form our own view about
what this virus is capable of then we'll
be able to look at the picture but as i
say review in it well it'll now be in
two weeks won't it if the measures have
been put in place but it seems to me
pretty sensible and proportionate off
the back of the fact that we're in a
much better place than a lot of
countries right the decisions we made in
the summer are paying dividends now the
booster program is going really well 20
million people now i think in rising
i've got my booster a week today hope
you've had yours k you know people are
really building their enthusiasm now for
that program
and if we carry on as we are then
hopefully all will be well
thank you for sharing with my audience
uh minister that i'm a lot older than
you uh pre-travel covid test no mine is
delayed mine's delayed because i had the
i had covered well say to minister
wellesley
you weren't like yeah
okay
yeah and i had mine early uh i didn't uh
pre-travel covered tests of day two
pre-departure tests why did we ever get
rid of those you know if we're only
going to put those in as a knee-jerk
when we get one of these variants in
it's already too late you know we need
to shut the door before the horses
bolted
well no we have to be agile right we
have to recognize that all these things
are impositions on people's uh lives and
lifestyles they're obviously extra cost
and they cause difficulty for the travel
industry now we need to try and smooth
that as much as possible and be
proportionate about our response you
know i we've got family overseas we're
going to be traveling at christmas we're
having a test in and out in and out both
ways and it is a total pain especially
if you've got kids right so we
understand that and so we have to be
proportionate and make these judgments
at the right moment that's what we've
done and it feels to me as if in the
face of the unknown on this virus at the
moment for the next few weeks that's
where we need to broadly be but but
surely they're only ever effective if
they're left in place until we see the
back of this pandemic otherwise we're
saying oh it's already in we need to put
these day two test pre-detaching tests
in again it's too late by then
well i don't think it necessarily is i
mean obviously there's lots of testing
going on right we're in a great place on
testing people got used to it they
understand it but there are lots of
requirements around the world and
there's movements of virus around the
world that we need to pay attention to
so being agile it strikes me is the best
thing we want to try and live as normal
a life as we possibly can as the various
you know evolutions of this virus work
their way through the system and that
means that we're going to have to you
know duck and drake a bit i'm afraid now
prime minister is doing his best to help
us live as normal life as possible
recognizing that we don't know
everything we need to know yet about
different variations and that we might
need to do certain things like this as
as time goes on so i think the british
people generally accept that notion
okay here comes the christmas party
question
the uh police commissioner the uh london
police commissioner crested dick says
reports of this party or one of the
parties at number 10 on the 18th of
december have not been reported to her
should they be
well i got i thought somebody had
reports i read in the paper that some
labour mps had reported this uh supposed
event um i mean as i say okay i know
nothing about it i've been assured by
number 10 that no rules were broken uh
if there was a gathering of any kind um
uh for your information at the time i
was kicking indoors in basildon with
essex police on a drugs gang uh which is
what i'm here to talk about um but yeah
i mean the police will have a look it's
for them to form a judgment
she said that it's not been reported to
her if it has been reported to the
police should they investigate
well that's a matter for the police i
mean the police get reports all day
every day of things that have happened
and they make a judgment about that and
it would be wrong for me as the policing
ministers to seek to have a view um
about the particular police
investigation you know we don't
generally comment on those things but
right you you know we are assured that
i've been assured that everything she
did yesterday and didn't he at the time
the justice secretary did yesterday
and also deputy prime minister he said
if any rules were broken
um then the any if there was a breach of
the rules then it should be investigated
and
um if it happened indeed is what he said
but
if it did happen it would be a breach of
tier through tier three rules surely if
a crime potentially had been committed
it should at least be looked into by the
police
well you're asking me to answer a
hypothetical question about this issue
but my general view is that where crime
is reported the police should
investigate
um yeah i mean it's not really
answering the question is it and and you
know i know that uh the government is
also keen to have free speech over
prison privacy that's what we're being
told about at the moment so given that
there should be free speech over privacy
shouldn't the public know whether or not
there was a party at number 10.
well as i say the the questions have
been asked number 10 have said that
everything was complied with if reports
have been made to the police then
they'll no doubt have a look and form a
view about whether an offence was
committed or not as policing minister my
view is that if offences are committed
of any kind a report of the police there
should be an investigation by the police
they have to examine it and decide
whether they are going to pursue it and
that's a decision for them and not
something that i as a politician should
seek to influence whether it's but if
through yours yeah i understand
but it's just it's just really
irritating isn't it for the public i
mean if there was a gathering of any
sort that involved people getting
together having a drink after work then
that would have been a breach of tier
three rules on the 18th of december last
year and as a result it would have been
against the law so surely the public
should know whether that happened or not
i assume that any inquiry that is made
by the police will examine those issues
as i say number 10 are reassuring
everybody that all rules were complied
with during that period and i take that
reassurance at face value but no doubt
if the police are alerted they will have
a look and they'll form a view and we'll
all learn more about it in the days to
come
which brings me back to my question
which is should the police be
investigating an alleged breach of tier
three rules
well the police should be investigating
anything that is a historic crime that
is reported to them um it's hard for me
to go any further than that okay because
you know we don't generally um comment
on specific cases or inquiries as as
ministers that's not what proper for us
to do
but in terms of what the police's
responsibility is i think they're very
aware of that and reports are made that
inquiry should follow and let's see
where it goes after that
okay fast forward a year
what can and we can't do this christmas
season
well obviously the the prime minister
said you can go about your normal
business but there are some specific
restrictions around mask wearing so you
have to wear a mask in a retail
environment on public transport
obviously some restrictions which we've
discussed on on travel in terms of
testing to make sure that we're not
importing uh the virus but otherwise
what he said is that we should go about
our business i will be taking my team
for a christmas dinner next week out of
the restaurant of the west end to
support that
industry and also have some fun at the
same
time i hope you will be too we will be
massed up where appropriate and i'll be
taking a lateral flow test to make sure
that i'm a negative before i participate
as i did this morning before i came to
see you conscious as i am of your safety
too
thank you very much i did exactly the
same uh before i came in this morning
minister how many people will be in your
party next week
i think it'll be six of us
okay and what are you doing on christmas
day will you be in a family gathering as
well
we were speaking to sanji javed and he
was talking about if he was in a group
of maybe two or three hundred he would
take extra measures i'm not sure how
many of my viewers ever go to a party of
two or three hundred
uh well i if if you're interested i will
be overseas for christmas i hope um
having been tested appropriate on either
side the other half of my family are
canadian um so we'll be there we'll be
observing the the regulations in that
country
okay well good luck with your uh booster
job it doesn't hurt a bit and if you can
have your vac your flu vaccine at the
same time go for it
uh well i will try and do both i have to
say the first one i felt slightly dizzy
but then it's been fine so fingers
crossed yeah was it was it was it
astrazeneca though or what did you have
yeah i had azad twice
so that means i think this time i'll get
something different i have a general
pfizer so we'll see how it how it goes
but i have to say i was one of the lucky
ones when i had covered i didn't have
any symptoms i did my 10 days you know
constantly testing myself to temperature
wise but nothing happened so fingers
crossed it stays the same i feel for
people who've and i've got lots of
friends who've been hammered hard uh by
the virus it's been really tough a lot
of people but the booster is the way
forward and i'm so pleased that you've
had yours game
and you too um keep well minister thank
you very much indeed for joining us
thank you
thanks a lot cheers
and just a reminder if you are heading
out this morning then you can take us
with you find us on the mobile app or go
to our website and to our live blog to
watch the program there you can catch up
on our interviews on twitter as well at
k burley erin
and umar are cutting those for you right
now and they'll be on
our twitter feed in just a moment
meantime cases of the new coved variant
omicron
continue to rise there's new data
emerging on the picture in south africa
as well this morning
katie barnfield with us in the newsroom
uh hi katie good morning what are the
figures saying
good morning kay well indeed there is an
anxious weight for among scientists here
for more data on how severe this new
variant is and there is you know a lot
of focus on south africa as the country
where this new variant was first picked
up we are waiting
for data on house of severities at the
moment one thing we do know about this
new variant is that it appears to be
highly transmissible i think we have a
chart actually that we are able to show
you so if we look at the figures here on
november the 27th just last week there
were only two known omicron cases in the
uk but the numbers have risen sharply
since then total cases in the uk have
increased by more than 50 from saturday
to sunday that means a jump from 160 to
246 in just one day and as i say uh all
eyes on south africa at the moment uh
for more data on this variant we have
actually heard from cyril ramaphosa the
president of south africa this morning
he said the emergence of this new
variant is of great concern to him and
he says that it now appears to be
dominating
new infections in most uh provinces in
the country and while early indications
from that country
are the infections seem to be fairly
mild we heard some data from hospitals
from a small number of patients that
have been hospitalized in south africa
um that most patients who are
hospitalized there did not need
supplemental oxygen so well while it
does appear to be mild he says
they are preparing hospitals and they're
also going to convene a new coronavirus
council which will take whichever
measures are necessary to address this
variant
okay thanks very much indeed for the
update thanks a lot
well let's have a quick look at the
numbers for you 27th of november just
last week there were only two known
omicron cases in the uk but the numbers
have risen sharply since then total
cases in the ewing uk increased by more
than 50 percent from saturday to sunday
jumping from 160 still not big numbers
are they to 246.
in the most recent 24-hour period there
have been
43
992 new record cases
of covert 19 um another 54 deaths sadly
have been reported within 28 days of a
positive test that brings the total
number of deaths in the uk
to 145
605.
almost half a million booster and third
jabs were given in the latest 24-hour
period taking the total number of those
doses to more than 20 million
and some breaking news you're waking up
to this morning maya and mars former
leader aung sang
has been given a four-year prison terms
for incitement so let's bring in our
southeast asia correspondent siobhan
robbins joining us now as you can see um
hello to you siobhan it had been
deferred until this week what more do we
know
yes as you say this morning it's been
confirmed that ansan tsuchi has been
given a four-year sentence the ousted
president has also been given a
four-year sentence and the mayor of
napierdo a two-year sentence now and
sansu-chi's charges that she's been
convicted on are um basically for
breaking breaking covert 19 protocol and
for incitement
the covert 19 protocol is in reference
to actions over a year ago actually
where she waved past an election rally
after winning the election in 2020
and the incitement is actually to do
with statements that were put out after
her arrest so that charge was vigorously
fought by her lawyers but to no avail
she has been given this four year
sentence now to remind people and
sansuchi was the democratically elected
leader of myanmar her party resoundingly
won the election in 2020 but this year
in february the military staged a coup
and detained her and various other
politicians since then we've seen
widespread violence in myanmar security
forces killing more than a thousand
people since february more than ten
thousand people have been arrested
including ansan tsuchi and this isn't
over as you can
probably guess the reaction from human
rights groups to today's sentences have
been damning
has said this is basically bogus charges
the junta trying to crush the opposition
uh one of the international crisis
groups spokespeople text me to say this
is not a legal process it's a
retribution against ansang suchi
basically minna line who's the junta
leader is flexing his muscles and dr
sassa who is a representative of the
parallel government told sky news that
he was extremely concerned particularly
giving the fact that ansansuchi is still
facing further charges which in total if
given maximum sentences could see her
spending more than a hundred years in
jail oh my goodness okay siobhan thank
you thanks a lot
more than 3 000 homes in northern
england and scotland are still without
power as the uk prepares for a second
major storm to hit the energy networks
association has said that
3190 homes still waiting to be
reconnected as of two o'clock yesterday
the majority in the northeast of england
scottish and southern electricity
networks said power had been restored to
all 135 000 of its affected customers by
sunday evening
the met office is predicting gale force
winds of 45 to 50 miles an hour over the
next two days and is warning the newest
winds will cause further damage to
communities affected by storm arwen
rescuers in indonesia are continuing to
search for survivors after a volcanic
eruption on the main island of java
after villages were blanketed with ash
look at those officials warned residents
to remain vigilant as heavy wind and
rain brought search and rescue efforts
to a temporary halt in some affected
areas fourteen people were killed and
nearly a hundred people have been
injured so far when the semeru volcano
erupted over the weekend
our asia correspondent tom cheshire is
standing by for us hi tom 14 dead so far
more than a hundred
injured quite a lot of devastation
good morning here yeah this has um been
a lot of devastation actually a lot of
it to do with the winds and rain the
lava dome on top of this volcano the
highest on the island collapsed and that
led to this huge explosion ash flying 40
000 feet and yeah these terrifying
pictures of the clouds coming towards
villages and as you say sadly 14 people
at least have been confirmed dead nearly
100 injured and those injured have burns
which show
just how quick this was traveling just
how unexpected it was when it happened
on saturday now they have been trying to
do the search and rescue but that has
been hampered by
first of all just the nature of the
ashes is piling on top of cars people
have been digging with hands there's a
bridge that was destroyed by lava flows
which has made things harder and then
today uh the the rain and the wind
coming back uh having fears that search
and rescue workers could be in danger
from ash uh sliding down the mountains
so it is a very delicate balance
especially as you mentioned with the
idea this might not be over yet the
observatory the looks of this volcano
saying there is still a potential threat
people had been trying to come back to
see what was left of their homes if
anything to search for people who are
missing but they've been told to stay
away because there is the threat for
another eruption it's a very tricky task
right now for search and rescue workers
in the area currently pausing that
search and rescue operation but hoping
to resume it as soon as they can okay
thank you
let's talk about the volcano on the
spanish island of la palma it's
continuing to spew lava and gases into
the 11th week of activity the red hot
lava from cumbro viaco volcano has been
engulfing houses and flowing towards the
atlantic ocean even in daylight pictures
it looks incredibly dramatic doesn't it
authorities said uh yesterday that new
vents have opened up again on the cone
with several very fluid
flows
now a british teenager who was seriously
injured in a crocodile attack in zambia
is set to fly back to rejoin her family
in the uk in the next 24 hours emilia
osborne smith was bitten and dragged
underwater while white water rafting
near the victoria falls goodness me i've
done that myself in a video released by
the hospital the 18 year old said she
fully expected to lose her leg after the
attack
when the accident happened i fully
accepted the fact that i was going to
lose my foot okay and i accepted that
and i said to all my friends it's fine
i've lost my photo still alive
and then i was told that my foot's going
to be fine and i will be able to walk
again it's just such a relief
in other news this morning the annual
fur babies dog pageant took place in
leeds yesterday and it was every bit as
spectacular as you might expect before
we show you one of the big winners let's
have a look at some of the other
honorable mentions this is ted the pug
who's gone for the gingerbread man
outfit of the year and doesn't he wear
it well
here's missy the maltese who took to the
catwalk donning this spectacular
blue
number i think that's supposed to be
lots of chops from frozen do you
or a mermaid as my director says quite
right uh and here's keegan the west
highland terrier who went the extra mile
this year he dressed up as hansel and
even brought along his own gingerbread
house got to watch the pug with that
haven't you gorgeous gorgeous gorgeous
but the dog making the most headlines is
mia the cocker spaniel who won first
place
in the queen bell category and look
at her outfit you'd be barking mad
to think that she doesn't deserve the
title she's got everything about her
hasn't she the perfect pause
we'll be chatting to the shadow home
secretary yvette cooper in just a moment
but first i just want to take you to
italy or tell you about italy it's the
latest country to get tough on its
unvaccinated population after a handful
of confirmed omicron cases as of today a
green pass which is proof of vaccination
recovery or a recent negative test
will be required for buses the metro
local trains and indeed hotels are
europe correspondent adam parsons is
with us so they're talking tough as well
now
yeah well they've been talking to us for
a while because you have needed this
pass to actually go to work uh for a
while now in italy italy's got a high
vaccination rate well into the upper
range of 80 percent for its adults
clearly a country that was hit very very
badly by the first wave of the pandemic
and is now seeing an economic recovery
and it's clear that the the country's
leaders see a link between economic
recovery and high vaccination so how do
you push people uh to the remaining
outliers to get vaccinated well i think
they've looked at the models of austria
and germany and decided we just have to
make life more uncomfortable for these
people so you will need this pass to go
on public transport but also
if you are not vaccinated or not
recovered then you will not be allowed
in some places some leisure places
restaurants cinemas they simply won't
allow you into those places unless
you've got a past that says you're
either vaccinated or you have recovered
simply being unvaccinated but having a
test certificate
won't be enough i think this is an
important move that you are seeing
in in countries now is effectively
stigmatizing people who are not
vaccinated now we've seen germany go a
long way down that route similar rules
that they have brought in as well
and heading towards mandatory
vaccination austria is now releasing
some of that details of mandatory
vaccination and the huge fines that
could entail i think europe is beginning
to be very serious about cracking down
on the unvaccinated minority that it
sees as responsible for perpetuating
this pandemic
okay adam thank you
the government has unveiled a 300
million pound action plan to crack down
on drug crime in the uk at the same time
that the common speaker lindsey hoyle
has called on the metropolitan police to
investigate drug use within parliament
the policing minister kit malthus told
me that lifestyle users could be
targeted with new message such as
removing their passports and driving
licences and he also said that reports
of drug use in parliament don't surprise
him
that might involve we hope uh
interfering in their lives in a way that
brings about behavioral change we've
seen that in other parts of government
policy if you look at the child support
agency where people
i was responsible for that for a while
where people don't pay their support
courts do have a power to remove their
passport and their driving license these
are the kind of impositions on a kind of
lifestyle which we hope will bring about
behavior change over the next decade
if it's true that um 11 out of 12
locations tested in the house of commons
tested positive for class a drugs it
could be that some of your colleagues
find themselves in that
position well i i hope not there are
obviously several thousand people who
work on the estate and i'd be surprised
if there weren't some lifestyle uses of
drugs amongst them i have to say
joined by the shadow home secretary vet
coop and annually appointed of course
congratulations ms cooper thanks for
joining us this morning how surprised
would you be that there were drug users
in the house of commons
it's not something i've ever seen but i
think the speaker of the house of
commons is absolutely right to say this
has to be referred to the metropolitan
police you can't have a
um
an institution that's supposed to be law
making and in fact having within it so
much law breaking so i think it's
absolutely right that this is a properly
investigated
and what do you think about the
government's suggestion that people who
are convicted of of class a drug crime
should um in time potentially lose their
passports um and their driving licenses
well this we used to have all kinds of
arrangements for um drug treatment
orders for different kinds of responses
through the courts and a lot of that has
just fallen into disuse so we've gone
backwards really over the last 10 years
we've had for example a real loss of
neighborhood policing so that means
there aren't the police there to deal
with that drug dealer on the corner or
that's standing outside the local school
we've also had a 40 drop in drug
treatment in some areas as well so big
drops in drug treatment and it's that
combination i think of the lack of
action on policing pulling that back the
lack of drug treatment the cuts there
and then the lack of coordination
through the cause for some of these
measures is why we have gone badly
backwards so the thing we're looking for
at this strategy today is whether we'll
see action on each of those areas
coordinated approach with the courts but
also the investment in the treatment
that we need get people back into
treatment and in the criminal justice
system so you've actually got the police
to take this action because there's no
point in talking about any of this if
the police just aren't there to actually
identify anyone that's got a problem
we believe that in scotland if somebody
is convicted of a class a drug crime
that they should
probably get a fine from the police
rather than it
be taken any further taking the pressure
off the prison system what do you think
of that
well i think it's a bit unclear what the
different uh sentencing proposals are
that the government's coming forward
with that's what we're going to have to
look at today at the moment there's a
whole range of different things you can
have but we used to have a system where
the courts we had it was at one point
specialist drug cause we had a system
where the the courts could say right
we're gonna say testing or treatment is
part of your sentence is part of what
the court will order and that has just
fallen massively into disuse some of
those used to be used a lot you go back
10 years
and hasn't been much more recently so
that's why some of this it's unclear
whether the government is actually just
trying to reinvent a wheel that frankly
they really should have had rolling 10
years ago and we've had this lost decade
almost
so i hope that they're going to be doing
the right thing on some of these things
using the courts in the right way but
also using the police and public health
in the right way if you don't have that
mix of things together
you don't solve the problem
omicron variant are we overreacting no
hospitalizations no deaths it transpires
that we've known about it in the uk
since uh last uh since october
well i really hope that the omicron
variant will turn out not to be a
problem for our vaccine program not to
be a problem uh in terms of the the
response to the covet that we've already
got but i think we have to take
seriously the scientists when they say
look this is a different numeric we
don't know enough about it and it is
because it is significantly different we
have to slow the spread before the
vaccine the boosters are fully rolled
out and before we've done the research
so get the boosters rolled out but slow
the spread of the virus that's of the
variant that's why i called for the
testing just proper testing before you
get on an airplane from anywhere in the
world so that you've actually been
tested before you're on a busy flight
with a lot of other people the
government waited two weeks to bring
those tests in i think that was
irresponsible but i hope they're going
to get on top of it now
i did put that to the policing minister
and i said don't these tests need to
stay in place until we've seen the back
of this very because otherwise you are
literally closing the door every time
the horse has bolted and he said there
has to be a balance between what we do
and how people manage to go about their
everyday lives
well i think the thing about testing is
that we are getting used to that now
lots of people do lateral flow tests the
kids for school people for different
work for different jobs a lot of the
time so it just seems to me common sense
that you have a lateral flow test before
you get on an airplane that could have
loads and loads of people otherwise by
the time you might discover that you've
got omicron it could be a week later
after all of the delayed testing once
you get back
by which time all of those people you
were on an airplane with all of those
people you were on a train or a tube or
a bus with will then have also spread
right across the country so
testing just seems to be a simple common
sense thing to do that's why i just
can't understand why the government has
been so resistant to it
i'm gathering at number 10 downing
street on the 18th of december last year
um the police commissioner in london
crested dick says that she has not been
told about it you're the shadow home
secretary why have you not raised it
with her
well i understood this had been raised
with her and i think to be honest she
really should have noticed it in the
newspapers because there's been a lot of
reporting on it i think the government
is um has been disgraceful in the way
they're responding to this they keep
saying oh well we don't recognize
reports oh well the rules were followed
how can the rules have been followed if
they had a party on december the 18th
when they were telling everybody else to
cancel their parties when they were
telling everybody else to cancel
christmas and it is classic one rule for
them another for everyone else they
cannot do this especially in a public
health pandemic they have to sustain
trust in the things that they ask
everybody else to do and not just think
they can rip up the rules for themselves
and that means they also have to be
honest about what they've done rather
than this shenanigans trying to pretend
all nothing happened but never quite
saying it and everybody knows there's
something dodgy going on
but back to my point if the
most important
police officer in the country says she
has not been told about it and you are
an incredibly important politician in
the house of commons uh the leader when
it comes to um the home office and
policing for your party are you going to
lift the phone up to it today and say
okay i'm raising it with you now
well we may need to follow up on this
but i just don't understand that
response because you know i understand
that uh other mps have raised it
directly with her and and also that it
has been in the newspapers repeatedly so
i just simply don't understand this idea
of them not being aware of it now they
certainly obviously not been told about
it by the government because the
government seems to be just trying to
hide the fact that this happened i think
he's just just come back to
the
the core question which is they have to
just stick with the rules that they make
for everyone else they have to respect
them and they have to respect everybody
else across the country who they are
asking to make sacrifices and it's that
failure to do so it's not just about one
party it's about the impact it has on
trust right across the country and at
the moment actually we cannot trust this
prime minister we cannot trust this
government on anything like this
but just let me press that point if i
may because she was on the radio on
friday and she did say to my old mate
nick ferrari um i have not had any
communication about this personally it's
going to take you two seconds to lift
the phone to her she's going to take
your call isn't she
well i wanted to find out what's
happened because my understanding is
that this has actually been raised with
her and she has been sent um questions
about this by other mps by other london
mps as well
so i will look into what has happened
here
okay good to talk to you thanks very
much indeed for joining us thank you
thank you take care
you too tomorrow's here thoughts
tomorrow good morning morning k well the
government's big drug strategy being
unveiled today and labor understandably
saying that it's the government who've
cut back on drug treatment services over
the last 10 years or so and now they're
just trying to recoup it i would say
that this is an interesting new
direction though they're investing 900
million pounds i understand it over
three years that's a huge amount of
money um not just in
tackling crime and arresting people but
also in treatment so seeing it more as
of a health problem and seeing if that
new approach will make any inroads very
quickly on the christmas party yes um
kit malthouse says the police should
investigate if they are told a crime has
been committed and we know labour mps
have contacted
the met police since crested dick said
she'd had no reports and said you should
investigate it and he confirmed perhaps
for the benefit of his colleague dominic
rob that the police can investigate
things that happened a year ago and
should do if they believe the law has
been broken and you can see that labour
are going to keep pushing on that
because they say it's wrong that downing
street have not said what exactly took
place okay thanks very much indeed
thanks a lot well let's talk about
christmas parties this year in weddings
as well of course steve duggan a
celebrity party planner and founder of
stephen duggan events is with us now um
hello to you stephen thanks for joining
us what what are people planning this
year
it's a whole range of things i think
this year was intended to be the whole
rush of everything coming back and
everything kind of taken off again the
excitement was
crazy during the summer everyone was
just thinking about this christmas and
what events they could have
and so old old different range really
corporate events being our like one of
our our biggest
um within corporate companies this
christmas party season is the biggest
event of the year to kind of reconnect
people and a team morale just bringing
everything back together again and then
we have the private social events as
well
um which are obviously vital to
other people for their own personal um
enjoyment
but on the the corporate front we've had
a rush of bookings it's busier than it
was in 2019 coming up to that christmas
um but it's it's been really good but
obviously now we have this challenge all
over again to make this happen
and safely
um how
quickly or how soon do you feel that we
might get back to um normal again
whatever normal means as people say
these days
yeah yeah we have well we had hoped this
time last year even with our weddings
through the summer we thought oh
everything's going to be totally fine
2021 is the year and i i'm thinking more
now it's next year and obviously now
this year people have done more hot
desking people have kind of left office
units they're trying to think of
alternative ways to work working from
home being the main one um but i'm
thinking it would be probably next year
would be one of the main
one of the main celebration years where
everything kicks off properly and but
unfortunately the last few weeks with
everything booked for this christmas
we've now been hit with these challenges
where we have to put several several
measures in place um
which is has never really been done
because um we haven't had the chance to
have the events in the last two years
you've been doing one or two fancy pants
parties in your time though aren't you
yeah the odd one yeah so here and there
um obviously we have a lot of clients
celebrities are not like the only
clients that we do and but yeah we've
done some some nice things for a few top
celebrities
um i think we've got a bit of a clue
about one of them let's have a quick
there you go um fantastic
you can't reveal too much more than that
i know but good for you hopefully things
will get back to normal before too long
thank you so much for joining us steve
thanks for having me
what about wedding plans what about
people who are getting married at this
time of year what are they allowed to do
and not do let's talk about that in more
detail and sarah hayward is with us um
hi sarah it must be so challenging for
people uk weddings task force and luxury
wedding planner as well of course um can
they just what roles do they have to
abide by
at the moment there are no restrictions
on weddings but
since we returned to work in july and
you'll probably recall weddings were
pretty much off the table for most of
the pandemic for a little while we were
able to do weddings of 15 people
and then 30 people but we really got
back to work mid july
we've been managing um the backlog
um so now as well as the weddings that
were planned we're obviously busy doing
the backlog of weddings uh over 18
months of cancellations and
postponements
so people are being careful um we're not
seeing um
postponements and cancellations at the
moment and of course anyone who's booked
a wedding for between now and christmas
it's all planned and it's all paid for
but we're just seeing people take a more
cautious approach
okay so that there's no sort of
restrictions that we saw it in the
summer where people couldn't sing or
dance
or whatever
none of that moment we did meet with
minister scully two or three weeks ago
we spoke to his department again last
week and we were told just keep watching
the hospitalizations
is you know if the nhs is overwhelmed
that's when we understand and we hear
through the media that plan b might be
implemented but having looked at what
plan b might look like it isn't going to
affect the majority of weddings it's
going to affect weddings if they do
bring plan b
on your guests of several hundred
yeah and do you always have to have an
eye and and indeed your couple have to
have an eye on what potential
restrictions might be being brought in
somewhere down the pike
yeah we do i mean the the big one as you
said was that was no dancing no singing
and those restrictions were gradually
lifted as we moved towards things called
phase four at the time um but at the
moment the big thing that's being
affected for couples is honeymoons and
of course my sector overlaps
with travel tourism and general
hospitality who were already challenged
in other ways hospitality have got
staffing shortages and now we're seeing
these travel restrictions come in so
certainly the couples we're working with
you've got weddings over the next three
weeks to a month it's honeymoons that
that they're really nervous about with
travel restrictions meaning they can't
go to some places and coming back in is
going to cost them a lot more than they
thought that it would with testing
people actually get a lot of people get
married this time of year
um there's traditionally around 13 000
weddings in december we think that's
about double possibly slightly more than
double because of the backlog at the
moment so there are quite a few weddings
um
but it's traditionally our quiet season
but we're just catching up now with all
those postponements so we're pretty busy
oh lovely okay sir it's good to talk to
you thanks very much indeed for the
clarification thank you